Speaker 1: There's a guy who is a host on Newsmax.
His name is Chris Salcedo. When he had a radio
show I appeared on Chris Salcedo show, it was
completely bonkers. But we we just talked past
each other. It made note the interview made no
sense. Chris Saucedo now has a show on Newsmax.
And Chris Salcedo floats the absolutely insane
conspiracy theory that Nancy Pelosi wants Brett
Kavanaugh to be assassinated so that Joe Biden
will get another Supreme Court pick. And this was
said during an interview with Illinois Republican
Congressman Rodney Davis. Rodney Davis doesn't
even say, Chris, that's crazy. That's absolutely
insane, Nancy. Nancy Pelosi wants assassinations.
Now, this all relates to an incident that took
place with Supreme Court Justice Brett Kavanaugh,
where an armed man was, I guess, picked up by
police a block or two away from Brett Kavanaugh's
house. And he he was there because he was angry
with Brett Kavanaugh. And Chris Salcedo says,
you know, this might be a plan to actually kill
Kavanaugh in which Pelosi is involved. Take a
look at this. The height of irresponsibility.
Speaker 3: And a lot of folks are starting
to ask some questions out there. Congressmen,
they're openly wondering why Nancy Pelosi sat on
a bill that was passed by the Senate to protect
Supreme Court justices. Now she's moving after
an assassination attempt on Justice Kavanaugh. Are
Americans right to question if Pelosi was actually
hoping for encouraging violence, that could
lead to Joe Biden appointing a new Supreme
Court justice? Well, it's certainly questions
that Nancy Pelosi and others need to answer.
Speaker 1: Pelosi needs to answer, are you trying
to kill a Supreme Court justice so that Joe Biden
will get to pick? She must answer that question.
Speaker 3: It's imperative why she thought
somehow Justice Kavanaugh, after having an
assassin in his backyard, is somehow safe over the
weekend. We could have gotten to this bill last.
Speaker 1: Week, by the way. I don't know that the
guy was in the backyard. Not that it matters, but.
Speaker 3: But she chose to hold it up.
And she needs to answer as to why. I mean, it
was five years ago that this left wing gunman,
inspired by rhetoric like Republican
policies, are killing people
tried to kill me and my friends, by the way.
Speaker 1: Then they show pictures of his house,
which is which is really something else. So
this is an outrageous conspiracy theory. And
by the way, many of these people celebrated when
Ruth Bader Ginsburg died under. Understand that.
And speaking of which, you know, I've said before,
allegations are often confessions, like with the
whole election fraud, voter fraud thing leading up
to the 2020 election. What they were really saying
was, we're going to try to steal the election.
They were saying Democrats are planning to steal
it. What in reality was we are we they are
planning to steal it. Should it be looked at
as to whether Ruth Bader Ginsburg really just
genuinely died of disease? Now, of course, I'm
being tongue in cheek. I'm being facetious. But
if they all of a sudden are so focused on Pelosi's
trying to kill Kavanaugh, maybe it's another one
of these thinly veiled confessions. And one of the
things that is important here. First of all, the
absurdity of I mean, Kavanaugh has armed security
and all these different things, kind of weird that
Pelosi's going to try to kill him by sending, you
know, some deranged gunman with to his backyard
when there's all this protection. That doesn't
really make sense. But beyond that. Violent
conspiracies are not only often projection,
but they are very common in this. They're common
in fascism. They're common in authoritarianism,
where you have to constantly talk about these
violent threats, which are then used to justify
more authoritarianism. And I don't even think
Chris Salcedo is conspiracy theory is. So what
was well put together enough to really fall
under that? But they are a common sort of feature
that we often see will have this clip
along with others that we've played
on our Facebook page, which you can find
at Facebook.com slash David Pakman show